scientists in South Korea have converted
cigarette butts into material that coats
the electrodes of super capacitors for
extremely large amounts of energy
storage and this vampire plant sweet
talks its victims through DNA into
lowering their defenses allowing it to
tap into them and drain their fluids
Vsauce Kevin here this is mind blow it
turns out most people have herpes in the
u.s. it's estimated that 54 percent of
14 to 49 year olds have herpes simplex 1
and the worldwide estimate of HSV one
oral type and HSV to the genital type is
somewhere between 65 and 90 percent most
people never show signs of it because
flare-ups can depend on the strain and
the strength of the hosts immune system
and estimates on the older population
having the herpes virus are over 90% the
hyperlapse makes your action footage
look like a first-person video game it
smoothes out time-lapse first-person
video that's normally unwatchable shaky
by using an algorithm that estimates the
camera path removes redundant frames and
then renders a new stitch image blending
it all together and Microsoft is
currently working to make this publicly
available as an app the new horizons
NASA probe recently captured video of
Pluto and its largest moon Charon this
is the closest imaging of Pluto ever ten
times closer to it than Earth is and
they're planning on getting even closer
in January the bug juggler is a 70 foot
tall robot that juggles cars or at least
that's the plan Dan granite is building
a proof of principle arm that will
juggle 250 pound cast-iron weights that
will be controlled by a person wearing a
sensor sleeve and glove the glove
provides haptic feedback so that way
they can feel the weight of the juggled
object with the ultimate goal of
building a giant robot that juggles VW
bugs because why not researchers at MIT
recovered sound from recording video of
a bag of chips the visual microphone
uses a high-speed camera to pick up the
incredibly subtle vibrations on an
object surface and then those are
extracted to partially recover the sound
that caused them burn stents here's
audio of a kid
singing recovered from video of a foil
wrapper near the child at the time Oh
someday you may be able to power your
phone with sweat a wearable device
similar to a temporary tattoo features a
sensor that measures lactate which is
produced when sweating it strips
electrons from the lactate to generate
electrical current which is then stored
by a bio battery currently only a tiny
amount of power can be harnessed this
way but they're working on increasing
that so we can eventually power a heart
rate monitor or a smartphone this
real-time facial tracker with projection
mapping can instantaneously change a
face the software references points on
the model's face to maintain the
projection during movements altering it
from makeup or paint to more advanced
reflections and digital designs and
they're looking for ways to implement
this in movies and games finally
arcattack controls in our Pesci ater
with Xbox Kinect which outputs MIDI to a
Tesla coil to make music
I'm going to leave you with a thousand
robot swarm that self assembles into
shapes and as always thanks for watching